i don't care what they say about me i
just want to eat
which i realize is a lot to ask for
at a dinner party at least once a year i
like to bring in some of my kevin's
famous chili
the trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes i toast my own
ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
that's interesting
wow it's a little early for ice cream
it's never too early for ice cream gem
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
god yo michael this whole donna thing is
gonna be okay you just stop beating
yourself up i know well i hope you're
right we'll see what dwight says why do
we have to see what dwight says because
i have him investigating her i'm waiting
for a text up michael no no no no no
undo that undo that it's too late to
undo it i need to know otherwise this
thing is going to spiral out of a mock
michael okay i'm i'm going to talk
straight to you because i think you need
to hear it michael this is so disgusting
stop eating it
i have the best stocked survival shelter
in northeastern pennsylvania but
everything has a shelf life so i must
eat and then replace everything that's
about to expire
it's nice not to have to plan my meals
you're eating eight-year-old tomatoes
they're still good for another week you
know i think i might have some type of
cheese in the back of my fridge you
might like i've got some cheese you
might like too
in between my toes
hurting her all right picture this snowy
ash drizzles from the sky a rabid pack
of dogs surrounds you as the flame at
the end of your stick dies out there's
only one hope left for you the door to
my shelter you pound you beg dwight
please let me in but i ignore your cries
and do not let you in you want to know
why because of the sign that says no
pounding no begging no because you
laughed at me kevin will be eaten pam
will be taken slave
jim will be made a warlord's jester
meredith will do okay just say again
really loudly uh what happened okay
i burned my foot
very badly on my foreman grill and i now
need someone to come and bring me into
work you burned your foot on a foreman
grill i enjoy having breakfast in bed i
like waking up to the smell of bacon sue
me and since i don't have a butler i
have to do it myself
so
most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill then i go to sleep
when i wake up i plug in the grill i go
back to sleep again
then i wake up to the smell of crackling
bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's
perfect way to start the day
today i got up i stepped onto the grill
and i clamped down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
oh breakfast i got your sausage egg and
cheese biscuit yummy yummy thank you
ryan
what was the thing uh you needed me to
come in early for
um
the sausage egg and cheese biscuit
but thank you and why don't you just
take a couple hours off this is yours
home alone risky business
take your pants off run around
whatever you ought to do
i'm just going to take a nap in my car
till work starts okay
healthier
i'll watch those cards
thank you hi please tell me you have a
sweet pretzel left we do
and we have 18 different toppings we
have sweet glaze cinnamon sugar
chocolate white chocolate fudge m ms
caramel dip mint chip chocolate chip
marshmallows nuts toffee nuts coconut
peanut butter drizzle oreo sprinkles
cotton candy bits and powdered sugar
is there any way that you could do all
all of them the works you got it all
right
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
he's uh on a sales call
no message this is all i could find
eat it
you don't have to do that kevin i don't
know i'm glad this is happening thank
you michael
why are you eating stem first this is a
new food for me how else did i eat it
the other way
can i get some cheese whiz or
hollandaise no no cheese whiz no
hollandaise no chocolate sauce just eat
it come on here comes the airplane there
you go open open into the hanger there
you go
yep eat it
put it in your mouth and just eat it
take it off i hate it i don't care
whether you hate it you say you do it
all right eat it eat it
you're killing him michael all right all
right all right shh
okay i it's from fluffy park can i be
done
let me see if you swallowed it open your
mouth
under your tongue
oh god
things are a little slow here and
there's only so much cold calling you
can do in a day
turns out there's no limit to the number
of cheese puffs you can throw at
someone's face
we're getting pretty good at it
yes
[Music]
insert it in my mouth okay that's not
gonna make your pizza eating experience
any better trust me oh try me jim
just don't think of it as degrading
think of it as you happen to be moving
the pizza six inches this way and he
happens to be biting it i prefer for him
to think of it as degrading okay
crust first
okay
now the beer
beer mean jim
gentle
[Music]
hmm i've gotta go meet angela i love
this hog mama dwight said it's hog ma
what is more what i wouldn't give for a
big
mess of
tacos right now i can go get us some
tacos
brilliant
if you want me some money yes i can do
that
for um
for two tacos we probably need about
what uh twenty dollars or
twenty five twenty thirty thirty dollars
yes tacos won't sell
eight for three dollars
oh
great
okay
oh
oh you've done these tacos
well that hit the spot
um
very savoury uh what do you do with the
crispy holder oh here let's try this
again and don't put your finger in yeah
just hold it like that hold it to the
side right let's hold it to the side
like leave it
look at me like this dude this is a
wendy's restaurant
kevin okay um
could i just have a frosty and a baked
potato please you have to come to the
restaurant to order food well i'll send
somebody to pick it up just have it
ready and it's ready now
well put it aside
okay ryan you told toby that creed has a
distinct old man smell
i know exactly what he's talking about i
sprout mung beans on a damp paper towel
in my desk drawer very nutritious but
they smell like death
all done
what's wrong michael it's like a gum in
my hair
you do this
just
stinks don't touch it please don't touch
it you got a ton of dandruff okay let me
be how did you get gum in your hair i
was walking in and i noticed something
shiny under stanley's car and i got
under seat what it was and i messed up
my hair all for a stupid piece of tin
foil but best case scenario you thought
it was a quarter kill me
right now we have peanut butter in the
kitchen
i don't feel like peanut butter give me
an ice cream sandwich nope not for you
it's for your hair and it is 9am
no dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good
good too oh dom that's disgusting
wow a lot of calories
well just don't leave it on too long
keep massaging please
oh yeah that's nice
you